à la veille de la commémoration des 20
ans de la catastrophe de tchernobyl
intéressons-nous ce soir à ses
répercussions écologiques pour la france
il y a vingt ans les autorités
affirmaient contre toute évidence et
toute logique que le nuage radioactif
provoquée par l'accident n'avaient pas
survolé la france aujourd'hui le langage
a bien changé comme nous le montre
patrick esther eric chaney il aura fallu
vingt ans pour reconstituer avec
précision le passage du nuage de
tchernobyl en combinant les données
scientifiques existantes avec des
modèles mathématiques ce document prouve
de façon indiscutable que le nuage a
traversé une première fois la france
jusqu'à la bretagne le 1er mai avant de
revenir s'installer entre le 2 et 5 mais
surtout l'est du pays
la contamination de l'air étaient
essentiellement concentrées sur l'est de
la france et a généré des dépôts de
petites particules radioactives
notamment du césium 137 de lieu de 131
qui s'est déposé sur les végétaux sur le
sol ce dépôt dans le détail est très
contrastée dans le sens où il a été
déterminé par l'importance des pluies
est donc entre le nord-est de la france
en gros la moselle jusqu'à la corse
on trouve tout un chapelet de zones qui
ont été plus particulièrement impacté
par des retombées radioactives
la principale source d'exposition
consécutives à ces dépôts s'est faite
par l'alimentation de produits naturels
ou agricoles contaminés notamment le
lait frais les légumes à feuilles qui
ont intercepté ces dépôts et donc les
populations notamment celles qui étaient
dans l'est de la france ont reçu des
doses liés à cette ingestion l'amitié à
l'époque les autorités affirmé que le
nuage s'était miraculeusement arrêté à
la frontière de protection de la santé
publique il n'y a aucun risque
avec le recul nous savons aujourd'hui
que certains produits notamment par
exemple certains légumes
certains produits laitiers de certaines
zones de l'est de la france aurait pu
être évité d'être consommée pour
minimiser les doses reçues par les
consommateurs de ces produits ce qui
aurait permis à l'époque d'éviter à 2
millions 300 mille enfants le risque de
contamination de leur thyroïde parle
iode 131 radioactive les études montrent
qu'en france une cinquantaine de cas de
cancer pourraient en découler
directement en 1986 après l'explosion du
réacteur de tchernobyl
toutes les mesures de contamination
réalisé en france étaient centralisées
ici dans cette salle des compteurs des
mesures techniquement irréprochable mais
dont les résultats étaient présentés
sous forme de moyenne gommant les
extrêmes donc les plus forte
contamination
s'agit-il d'une erreur de méthode ou
bien d'un mensonge d'état
vingt ans après la question reste posée
le mensonge ou sur un nuage de
tchernobyl en france existe toujours 20
ans après la vérité n'est pas fait il ya
eu des contaminations tout à fait
importante dans certaines parties du
territoire
il aurait fallu donner des directives
pour ne pas manger tel ou tel produit et
surtout des sanctions doivent être
prises contre les autorités françaises
et l'industrie nucléaire qui a caché la
vérité
vingt ans après la catastrophe 60% de la
contamination radioactive par le césium
137 est toujours présente sur le sol
français